in 2020 egyptologist from the University
of bond deciphered the oldest known
place name sign in the world dating back
to the late 4th millennium BC the four
hieroglyphs inscribed on a rock in the
Wadi el- Malik east of oswan Egypt
declared the region the domain of the
Horus King Scorpion of course place
names otherwise known as toponyms
existed far before The Scorpion King
both the 2002 and the 3070 BC versions
but where do place names come from what
well toponomy reveals a lot about the
culture and history of a place including
the people who live there the nature of
the settlements and the geographic
landscape so that's your short answer
for the long answer including the
longest place names in the world join me
as we dig into the exciting world of
toponyms I'm Dr Erica brazowski and this
is other
[Music]
words other words
I love superlatives more than anyone so
the first thing I wondered was what's
the longest toponym growing up I thought
it had to be the nearby lake commonly
called Webster Lake but officially named
Lake chaga goag managa gag chaban gangam
Mak the name comes from the Algonquin
language spoken by the nipmuck people
indigenous to the area and is said to
mean Lake divided by Islands or fishing
place at the boundaries at 45 letters
it's quite a mouthful but while it's the
longest place name in the US and the
longest lake name in the world there are
a few other places that have it
completely beat according to Guinness
World Records Thailand's Capital holds
the crown for longest name you might be
thinking what Bangkok that's shorter
than Los Angeles well Bangkok is
actually a colloquial name most popular
with foreign visitors the locals usually
call it K which means City of Angels and
is a shortening of the official
ceremonial
name
Mah
Mah Mah popat
R Mah Satan Amon a
s in English that's City of Angels great
city of Immortals magnificent city of
the nine gems seat of the king city of
Royal palaces home of gods incarnate
erected by V pararam at indra's beest
but that's several words isn't it to
find the longest one-word place name
let's head further south to New Zealand
where there's a hill the mai have named
taaki tahu which means the place where
tatea the man with the big knees who
slid climbed and swallowed mountains
known as land eater played his nose
flute to his loved one not to be
confused with a nearby Hill where Toma
the man with the big knees who slid
climbed and swallowed mountains known as
land eater played his accordion to his
loved one just kidding I made that up if
those are the longest place names what
are the shortest three letters two
believe it or not there are more than 40
places worldwide named with just one
letter you've got your a e i o u and Y
with various diacritics but also d g h l
and W hey easy to spell then wondered
what's the most common place name
according to the US Geological Survey
fair viiew and Midway are competing for
the most common place name in the United
States with 288 and 256 locations
respectively but neither comes close in
terms of number to the winner of the
title San Jose with more than 1,700
locations worldwide the name is so
common likely because many of the cities
and towns were founded by
Spanish-speaking mission Aries who chose
the name St Joseph for his significance
to their faith in fact the top nine most
common toponyms were named after saints
history is built into place names
sometimes it's as clear as a new name
because those who thought they were
discovering SLC colonizing lands wanted
a reminder of back home hence New
Caledonia New Zealand New Orleans and
Nova Scotia there's also been a
tradition of naming these questionably
acquired lands after Colonial monarchs
which is where we get all the georget
towns and Victorious recently movements
to throw off Colonial names and reclaim
either indigenous ones or new
non-colonial ones have become popular
limbe Cameroon for example was formerly
called Victoria and there's been a
political push to add AOA to New
Zealand's official name interestingly
despite shifts in power due to say
Invasion toponyms tend to be conserved
surviving repeated language shifts the
United States is is full of places that
kept their Native American names even as
the people who named them were forced
out and all over Western Europe we see
cities with Celtic names like London
Paris Vienna Milan gent and Zurich none
of which are home to the few surviving
Celtic languages even more specific
history can be baked into toponyms in
the British Isles you can deduce a fair
amount about a location settlement
demographics from its name for example
Sussex is the land of the South Saxons
Buckingham is the home belonging to
bucka and canterberry is the Fortified
town of the people of Kent this type of
naming tradition based on residents is
far from extinct think ethnic enclaves
like little Mogadishu Telus or Basque
block that are named after the global
locals that the residents immigrated
from Native American place names May
describe not only local topographical
knowledge but also information about
resources available at certain times of
the year Manhattan is derived from the m
word manah hatan meaning place for
Gathering the wood to make bows
Massachusetts is derived from the wag
word musasa meaning near the great Hill
or at the range of hills and Mississippi
is derived from the ojibway word missii
meaning Great River occasionally a place
named no longer reflects the current
landscape Back Bay in Boston is a
bustling Metropolitan neighborhood but
has the name of a water feature curious
well history tells us that it used to be
a bay until it was filled in in the mid
1800s but the name stuck what about Wall
Street the actual Street not the metonym
for big business or financial markets
Wall Street in New York City has a bowl
and fancy buildings but no wall the
street was named for a defensive wall
built in 1653 that was removed less than
50 years later yet somehow that Legacy
still lasts inspiration for toponyms can
come from history history myth climate
geography and more but most important
they're a reflection of our shared
experience on this planet called Earth
before you go we're looking for your
feedback each year PBS digital Studios
conducts an audience survey it helps us
understand what you like and what you
want to see more of you also get to help
PBS pick new shows it only takes a few
minutes but your feedback is extremely
valuable to us there's a link in the
description thanks in advance
M
yes that was I'm happy with
that